معنا ولكن لا نزال نشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره والتي
تصلون مشاهدينا من غازي عنتاب وتظهر اذا
احد المباني الذي تهدم بالكليه
الجراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
قبل حوالي ساعتين من الان فقط
شده الزلزال بحسب اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه كانت قوتها 7.4 درجات على مقياس
ريختر وقد ضربت ناحيه باسارجيك في محافظه
كهرمان مرعش جنوبيه البلاد هناك بعض
المراكز المختصه بتسجيل الزلازل
ذكرت قوه اكبر
بقليل من هذا هناك من تحدث عن سبعه فاصل
ثمانيه او سبعه فاصل تسعه بحسب هيئه
الزلازل الامريكيه او الاوروبيه ولكن ما
قالته اداره الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه هو
7.4 درجات على سلم ريختر وزير الداخليه
التركي كان قد ادلى بتصريح قال فيه بانه
تم تسجيل ست هزات ارتداديه تجاوزت شده كل
واحده منها الست درجات على سلم ريختر يعني
نتحدث عن عدد مهول من
الهزات الارضيه اذا كانت تلك الارتداديه
تتجاوز شدتها الست درجات على حد ما قاله
وزير الداخليه التركيه
تتواصل هذه الاخبار ولكن
نعود ربما لعمر حوراني لا ادري ان عاد
الينا الان لمعرفه تفاصيل اكثر وهو موجود
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا من محافظه غازي
عنتاب التي
تهدمت فيها بعض الابنيه وهذه صور اخرى مثل
ما يشار اليه هي من ديار بكر تحديدا وتظهر
كذلك انهيارًا لمبنى او لمبان اخرى
سيارات الاسعاف موجوده تلك الادوار تدلل
على ذلك
وبالتاكيد الحديث عن حاله الهلع والخوف
لدى السكان الذين احسوا بهزات ارضيه
متتاليه خلال فتره
وجيزه اعلاها كان بشده 7.4 درجات على